[Music]
all right hello everyone
uh this is gm josh fidel and today i'll
be conducting the insane and the end
game lecture
uh this i think will be the last week of
this and then we're switching up the the
lectures to do different things
uh so today i wanted to show a couple
games that occurred recently in the tata
steel tournament
uh i'm going to show one and if there's
time i'll show another i never know how
the pace will be
i am looking at chat so good evening
everyone i can see you guys uh so and i
will be asking you guys questions so
feel free in the youtube chat to
you know suggest moves and do things
like that ask me questions
so
i wanted to talk about end game
technique today
so
there are textbook end game techniques
like especially the games of capablanca
it shows pristine beautiful end game
technique and that's really great to
learn that's things to
to figure out
and i really recommend studying that
but this is more what i'd call real
world technique meaning that
this is what happens in a regular game
even between two elite gm's
part of it is that because people defend
really well like nothing against
capoblanca's play but a lot of his
opponents defended very poorly or they
played passively and you don't see that
too often
even players who are not as advanced
like even you know amateur players
whatever they still know to play
actively and defend actively so most
games don't look like papa blanca's
games also most of us are not as good
as capablanca at this so
it's important to know how to you know
navigate your way through technique when
it's not perfect when there are so many
flaws and there are so many
complications because a lot of the times
you can't just win smoothly you have to
try to go with roll with the punches and
figure things out and this game between
dubois and grendelus which i'm showing
now is a great example of that
and this was actually a really cool one
because i showed a game before between
gordalius and carowanna where
grendel is lost and grenellis has been
having a rough tournament so to get a to
try to beat dubov was pretty big
so
all right and hello everyone hey someone
from maine i'm actually from new
hampshire so maine was very close by
anyways knight c6
was played in the game but i wanted to
talk about this position first so
in this position
black is up a pawn
but i would argue it's not a super clear
pawn i mean you have these you have this
extra pawn the a pun but it's not going
to queen anytime soon i would argue the
rook on a4 is a little bit
off at least sometimes like it's active
but it also can end up stuck there
so this position and again like i would
say the king side pawn structure is kind
of tough for black cause activating your
king is difficult white has ideas of
just pushing
so i believe that this position is
actually quite difficult
so
live free or die exactly
uh knight b3
uh was played here by dubois which makes
sense trying to maybe play knight c5
controlling some queen side squares
so this position i wanted to show
what
the some of the difficulties
for
for black so what would you guys play
here is black i'm kind of curious
all right
yeah i actually don't know i'd say this
is a french pawn structure though the
these three pawns here but i don't think
it came from a french it came from
something else i believe but it could be
karo khan because of what happened over
here so
it depends
so i'm seeing b pawn pushes b6 makes
sense to restrict the knight the
drawback to b6 is you don't really have
a follow-up plan that i can see
so let's say you play b6 here i think as
white i would probably just play f4
and the idea is that i'm just going to
start pushing my pawns over here and
it's going to be very uncomfortable
so here's kind of the real question
would you play like b5 is what was
played in the game so we'll go over that
knight a5
is a very reasonable move which i looked
at so probably white should trade uh the
knights
and i would say this rook end game again
if it were balanced then maybe black
would just have a winning position but
because this pawn structure because it's
really hard to push i think this is
difficult
so white can play f4
and i actually think black has a clever
idea of playing rook a6 so the idea here
is what do you think my idea is if you
play f5 now
what do you guys think black could play
again i'm looking at youtube chat seeing
what you guys have to say
kf8 is possible but the problem with a
move like king f8 is i play f6
and i feel like if your king runs too
far i'm just gonna try to queen over
here and otherwise your rook again is
kind of stuck
so this is not really what i'd like rook
b6 check's possible but i just move out
of the way i don't know if you're
achieving too much
b5 i would argue the same like i can
play with f6 at some point
but manny has it i think f6 so this
prevents the pawn push and if we trade
all these pawns it's really going to
favor black because this rook kind of
gets out and then the extra pawn can
really make a difference i still don't
think this is an easy win or something
but this is at least a decent idea the
problem for us as black is that white is
in no way obligated to play f5 white
could play rook f1 rook g1 any kind of
improving move let's say rook g1 may be
trying to play g5
and it's still really tough to just win
this game this rook just can't enter the
position that's the main problem
so sure eventually black can play rook
c6 rook c4 b5 b4 trying to break apart
these pawns but it takes a lot of time
and in the meantime you have to worry
about g5 stuff and f5 eventually is
still coming it's just a really really
tricky position to win
so 985 was a possible move but i don't
think it was that clear instead
grandelias played b5
so here i have two questions for you
first of all
what is black's aim with this move
and the second question is how should
white respond white's move here is
actually extremely important
and yeah
bob i see these questions a lot like do
you want to trade when you're up
material and stuff and in general yes if
you could trade off the knights and the
rooks and then get a king of hunting app
upon you'd be winning that's that's nice
but i would also say that sometimes
trades aren't that simple like trading
nights into a rook end game sometimes
rook end games can be drawish and here i
don't know if the trade of knights
actually helps black that much
sometimes having the knights makes the
win easier
so you have to be careful about this
dogma that you should trade when you're
ahead a lot of times you should not
one of my pet peeves is when people
trade queens when they're attacking
because they want to go to a pawn up end
game rather than just continue attacking
upon up
but that's another story
so white can play knight d2 but the
problem is this move is very passive
uh it puts a knight on a more passive
square and something like b4 is coming
which i think is going to be very strong
so i don't think knight d2 is the best
move
so b5 b4 is surely black's threat i
absolutely agree with that for example
let's say this f4 move again
i play b4 and all of a sudden you have
big problems
if you try to play f5 just ignoring my
play
i have different options but even just
takes
rook c4 check you have to defend this
pawn knight before check and this is
just a disaster my pieces are becoming
extremely active the fact that i have
this pawn on a7 is actually not even the
most relevant thing
mainly the problem is that your pieces
just get kicked around here you can't
allow play a move like this because of
the fork
so you'd have to play back i can check
you here you have to go back i go here
and this is just an example of like kind
of a nightmare
this is what black wants right like you
have to go back to c1 and
or maybe you have knight d2 uh but okay
black can even play a move like this
just trying to take this pawn but this
is an example of a position where
everything is going wrong
uh for white
so i would really not recommend that
king e2 may have been a better defense i
saw someone mentioned that
but this is exactly what white does not
want
so the question is how do you deal with
the move b4
so ken has the right idea which is you
play the move rook c1
and this is what i mean by modern
defense i feel like in capablanca's day
most chess players at least would not
find a move like rook c1 or at the very
least it wouldn't be consistent
and because of that
they
they would not um
they would just die like b4 would just
kill them and i think that because
defense largely due to improve computers
has improved so much it means that your
opponents are going to find moves like
this and make your life difficult
so here
grandelias does opt to play knight a5 my
main question is what does rook c1 do to
prevent b4
what do you guys think how does rook c1
help stop b4
the knight hangs so that's part of it
and yeah i actually didn't um i'm
actually not 100 sure but i think that
both moves look very possible here so c4
the idea is that now c takes d is a
threat it takes rook takes and you can
see how important it is the placement of
pieces
the fact is that this rocket e4 just is
really badly placed and because of that
white's kind of crashing through if
black tries something like this you can
trade and take this pawn at the very
least
so it's actually a very very annoying
position maybe black can try something
like this to put a knight on d5
but even here this rook on a4 is
actually a really terrible piece
and i feel like even here you can play
this followed by rook takes pawn and
this is not going well
i'm not really sure exactly what black
should try maybe something like knight
moves immediately is possible
but even here right like if takes the
knight and then c5 is a move you have to
worry about even just king b3 trying to
take this pawn i feel like things have
gone horribly wrong for black
c takes b also looks possible though
with the idea that after knight takes
and keep in mind you can't take with the
rook now that's the key because the
knight's hanging
so here you have to play check
and rook c7 something like this and here
you have to be careful after rook a2
check you can't go to c3 because of rook
c2 check skewering
but you can go back here and i feel like
i guess rook takes f2 guards the f7 pawn
though that's kind of the problem so
probably still good for still good for
black
so
most likely the more accurate way to
play is just with c4 although i have to
say this might also have some
possibilities like after a check
maybe here you have to play a sneaky
move like knight c1 to stop knight d3
and this and now you're threatening king
b3
so even this maybe not so clear but
overall i think c4 is in a simpler way
to do things
but roxy one is definitely the best
defensive move no doubt about that
so you can play a move like king f8
trying to improve your king this is kind
of my instinct here
but even here i couldn't really find
anything after f4 king e7 f5 i wasn't
sure who improved more i mean white gets
this move in which is really annoying
and i don't really see what to do like
b4 still just doesn't work for me
so i don't
really think this is a big improvement
for black so even though this is what i
kind of wanted to do i didn't think it
was so simple
so
let us see so in the game
ah yes he played knight a5
so in the i i guess my main question for
you is as white would you retreat the
knight or take or play knight c5 what do
you guys think what would you guys do
here
so i see some people say retreat some
people say take but i don't see too many
reasons like once people said daniel
probably plays 92 to keep pieces on the
board
uh i would argue though that keeping
pieces on the board doesn't necessarily
help you draw here like i think trading
into a rook end game
is not a bad way to try to draw so i
think it really depends
keep in mind also that after 92 it's
very possible to play knight c4 check
right so you're not really stopping the
trade anyway
so knight c5 was suggested the problem
with knight c5 is that
i can play the move knight c4 check and
this move is very nasty because your
king just doesn't have a safe home if it
goes here i check it
if it goes to c2 i can i can check it on
a2 so you'd have to go somewhere like
this but now at the very least i can
just play rook a3 and this feels like my
knight and rook are very strong it's not
on c5 it's on an outpost it looks pretty
but it does almost nothing
it's one of those nights that's just
like it looks nice but it really doesn't
help your position
so i would argue that this position is
very very bad for white
so knight c5 i don't like 92 was played
in the game
knight takes c5 i think would be
probably the best
um the best try
and once again you go to this rook end
game in playoff 4. so the fact that
black has to move b5 in is
is interesting but not necessarily that
bad like black can try to play rook a4
for instance but here you can play f5
and the problem again is that b4 runs
into king b3 so you can't really play
that move so easily and in the meantime
white just has this nasty kind of
counterplay
and if white black tries to play rook c4
and b4 you have the option of moving the
rook to a more active post so say rook
a1 threatening the a pawn
and again i just don't think this is so
easy i think that once white rook gets
active the fact that white's pawn
structure is more advanced and a bit
better meaning this king is not so good
is going to cost black a lot
so
black can maybe try rook a6 again with
this f6 idea but even this i just didn't
think was so clear f5 is still playable
but white can also just try to bring the
king up or something like that and
it's just not so easy i think that this
position is going to be very very
difficult to win for black
but i still think that there are chances
right like it's not unplayable i'm not
saying 95 is a bad move i think it was a
difficult choice
but i would argue that
probably white should go for this
capture
uh the black oh you mean the position
with uh knight c5 i see
um
so yeah after knight c5
yeah the problem here is that the black
rook is stuck for the moment but the
white rook is also stuck and the knight
can't move either because it would allow
this
so in a way i'd say that all of white's
pieces are stuck whereas just our rook
is stuck and in the meantime by the way
we can play a5 b4 to free our rook
anytime we want
so i would argue that even though the
rook's a bit stuck it's only stuck
temporarily and i think that in the long
term like the knight on c5 just does
nothing so
uh maybe white can try f4 f5 but i don't
believe it i think that
uh black's gonna crash through with this
pawn pretty soon
so in the game dupont played the move
knight d2
and this move i think is probably not so
great but the question is how would you
take advantage of it from the black side
yeah but thanks for the question one i
would say that a lot of people probably
have the same question like why is black
doing well with such a stuck rook so i'm
happy to answer questions like that i
think that usually if you have a
pressing question about the position
someone else is wondering the same thing
is usually what i tell people when i
teach classes so
i'm always glad to get those questions
so knight c4 check is one option what
other options does black have and which
one which one do you like better like
what are your what's your reasoning
yeah i agree with you scott it's a very
complicated game and i would say
grandelias played this phase of the game
beautifully but even at certain later
points he still
uh could have spoiled it so it's and not
not because he's like has bad endgame
technique or anything like that it's
just such an immensely complicated
position
uh but that means it's a lot of fun for
us to go over i i like going over games
that are messy like this sometimes more
than the the beautiful clean copa blanca
games can be nice but at some point like
you know when you see games like this
with you know changes and all this like
all these complications things that are
hard to figure out at least to me that
resembles more of you know what our
games would look like like i don't get
to play too many games with like
clear-cut beautiful plans that never get
spoiled you know it just it's not how
tournament chess works generally
so knight c6 trying to play a5 is is
logical but i can also move my knight
back and then white's doing fine
so
so a lot of you are suggesting knight c4
check i think this would be a mistake
after knight takes c4
so first of all if rook takes c4 you
have to deal with rook the rook getting
active with rook a1
if
b takes c4
so d take c4 i can play f4 and the
problem is that
this f on is still coming and b4 is
never good and this rook on a4 is really
an just not a good piece
it would so much rather be out and i
guess you can play like this but at some
point i can still play f5 and eventually
rook a1 when your rook moves
i can also think about something like d5
here
followed by this and trying to take your
pawn and this also looks very promising
to me i think that because black's
king's so passive it's just going to be
very very difficult here and if you take
with the b pawn
i can play f4 again
and let's say rook a6 f5 immediately
does run into f6 i believe but let's say
white plays a move like rook g1 just for
example how is black going to make
progress here if check i can probably
just bring my king over
and again what are you doing if you move
your rook back i go back if you push
your a pawn i just attack it you
basically have no plan here at all
so i think that even though you've
simplified quote unquote i think that
you've simplified into a position where
winning for black will be very difficult
because you just don't have a winning
plan and it's because you're kind of
getting owned on the king side here
your king side so paralyzed you can't
just win on the queen side so you'd need
kind of a second front something like
that
so i believe that grandelias found a
much stronger move than knight c4 check
and as i mentioned this part of the game
grendelias played beautifully he really
did like he did everything he's supposed
to do
so king f8 is a an improving move but i
don't think it actually contributes
towards winning the game right away so
why could so for example white again
could just push this f pawn and i don't
think that your king improvement helps
your position quite enough
i think that you want to look for
something more immediate
sometimes like these positions there are
two types right where there's a position
you want to play improving moves
building moves just trying to get your
pieces better and then there are
positions where you have to strike
because your opponent's a little
vulnerable or because you have a
particular idea
the main thing for me is that this rook
on a4 i just hate so much
i really don't like this rook
and a reminder to you guys by the way
knight c6 knight b3 gets to the previous
position so that doesn't help black very
much
trying to push pawns on the king side
like white can usually just ignore you
uh like i'm never obligated to take your
pawn and that means that you're not
really achieving all that much
so how do you activate this a4 rook
that's the question i would ask myself
b4 very nice and this is the move that
you want to play for right you're trying
to break apart the pawns and now your
rook's going to come into the fray and
take
uh d4
so once again in this messy messy game
dubov has a very difficult choice to
make does he take this pawn or does he
push c4
i think those are the main choices
allowing black to take
is probably not wise so which choice do
you think is better
seeing some pushes that's good
c4
well guess what guys you guys have
better end game instincts than do both
at least in this instance duboff took on
b4 which i believe is a big mistake c4
and the game still is immensely
complicated
so black does have a very very nice idea
here
so i wanted to show it so first of all
yeah so knight takes c4 check is
possible
but i don't think this is so clear
something like this and a5 was one idea
but the problem
is that white can get counter play on
the seventh right i can check play rook
c7 so once again this rook is awful
right you can't just leave it there you
don't want to allow rook to x7
so b3 i think is
best and this is where it gets really
complicated so
if white simply plays rook takes f7 then
rook takes d4 is a big problem you're
threatening a4 and if you take on b3 i
take here it's just
quite a few too many puns
so i think best is actually to play d5
and the idea is now after it takes takes
your pawn structure is much more broken
up
so for example now if you take and i
take your pawn here is a lot weaker so
i'm threatening to play f4 i can play
rook d7 and try to grab your pun
this position i'd say is a lot more
unclear
so actually rook b4 i think is best
trying to push this pun
but now white can play e6
a4 and this is where it gets crazy e7
and keep in mind not all this is
completely forced and obviously to find
this during a game would be very
difficult
so the idea now is if you try to play a3
check
and b4 i actually can queen first
and here i can it looks like my king's
in a lot more peril but i can at least
give perpetual i can sack and give this
perpetual if i want i could also try to
take your rook but i don't know it's it
doesn't feel
all that winning or anything
uh oh wait a second yeah yeah so oops
where did i go oh no
lost my place okay uh
so it was c4 knight c4 this was the line
i was looking at so this whole thing and
this is kind of crazy but i think that
in the end
black's uh doing okay uh white's doing
okay so rookie four i looked at and here
believe it or not white only has one
move and i want to see if you guys can
find it this is quite something
because again my idea is just to go here
and then my pawns are just going to go
they're just going to roll
not to mention if you know i can just
try to do this as well like i just have
so many ideas here
so you need to do something very
forceful as white but what forceful
thing can you do
yeah this is where insane in the end
game gets its uh gets its name right
and i think i mentioned this one of our
previous lectures you can just prepare
end game material but i remember when i
used to do this i before i would always
just find the most complicated end games
i could and try to explain them just
because i take all the titles very
literally
rook f4 very nice
so the idea of course is if you take the
nyqueen
so you have to kind of check king a3 and
this again is where things get crazy
if rookie tuck king b4 b2
you actually can queen and then hide
your king on a5 and white's probably
doing okay
because this king is hard to attack
this is how insane endgame can get guys
so pretty crazy
uh there's also the move b2 immediately
and now you have to play rook b4
rook takes a7 rook takes b2 so it's a
bit more sane rook e4 so black's still
on top but i think it's very difficult
to win after something like f3 rook f4
rook d2
takes
takes
check here
takes takes i think black's just white's
just in time because if you try to play
this so a lot capturing would just lose
because the king runs up
but you have this move and you're just
in time to draw for white
so just again to give you an idea of how
amazingly complicated these situations
are
even for grand masters this is just
really hard to figure out
so this is the insanity that these lines
can get but this was just one line
the other line is the move b3
so first of all after knight takes b3
knight takes e4 check is completely
winning but i think rook b4 and trying
to win a piece is
pretty straightforward
so
the best move is c takes d5
rook takes d4
and this outline also gets crazy knight
takes b3
rook takes d5 white trades the knights
and you get to this rook end game at
first my impression was this rook end
game should be pretty easily winning
because the white king is so far but
it's actually still not so easy
the time situation i don't really know
i'm afraid
but i would imagine that trying to find
all this with any period of time is very
difficult
so in this position yeah this was
actually quite interesting after rook
takes e5 rook takes f7 i think white's
pawn structure is better and this a
pawn's not so easy
so it's better to play this in order to
take this pawn instead
because now if you try to play f3 i have
rook f4 and this pawn is very weak
so you should take take
and here things also get crazy king c3 i
think is a very important move
trying to approach the pawns
rook g5 forking
king d4 and the key idea now is that
you're going to play for a very strong
e-pawn so you're not even worried about
taking the apon
the apon so much it's almost not so
relevant
the main idea is to get active and get
an active king
and this is something which i'd say this
pattern is something people should be
aware of that often in these rook end
games getting an active king and a
strong pass pawn is more important than
the pawn count because this final
position which i analyzed
white's you know gonna be still down a
pawn and black has connected passers but
white has the better king and the more
dangerous pawn so i think that this is
very very drawish
was an hour ahead of nils wow
yeah that's that's that makes nils play
even more impressive honestly and maybe
duboff should have slowed down
but uh i think that dubois also he lost
a game on forfeit probably mentally he's
not in the perfect place i mean he's a
professional right so probably he
can recover but it's a difficult
situation i think for anyone even if
you're a pro so
in any case i think that because white's
pawn is very very strong
the drawing chances are very high there
so again these are just some examples
um
but uh it's still not so simple so rook
takes f7 yeah rook takes g4 and this is
only one move this is only one line that
i gave right there are so many different
lines and variations
but the main thing to remember here
is that as white you only have to choose
between takes b4 and c4 you don't have
to see till the end of end of the earth
right
you just have to see the differences and
i would say that c4 looks much more
complicated and harder to win than c
takes b4 does
because b3 and and taking the pawn looks
scary but it's clear that in the rook
end games you at least have some minor
chances whereas i would argue that after
this which is what happened in the game
in black plays knight c6
between the weak d4 pawn and the stable
black pieces
this is just a dead lost position
now that doesn't mean that it's going to
be lost every time in fact he's still
got his chances to draw
but i would argue that
he should just not avoid this
compared to the other line like he
doesn't have to see all the rook end
game stuff
uh we leave that to to
to computers and whatever else but like
in a game you just have to see what is
simple and what is not and i would say
that
that this is much easier to play and win
for black than the other position
because here i mean you want to defend
this pawn with a move like knight f3
right but here
okay even a5 is winning but if i just
check and trade rooks and playoff six i
think you're just gonna lose cause
if you allow me to take i create another
protected pass pawn and if you take and
i take i'm ready to play like this and
bring my king in and the a pun's gonna
run like this is just not a position
where you can hope to
hope to draw
so i think that pushing c4 would have
given him a lot more better chances
so in the game he played king d3 but
again it was not over
knight takes d4
rook c8 czech rook c7 so it's still
complicated to deal with it's not like
this is trivial but it definitely should
be winning
so nils plays very well at first he
pushes his pass pawn
knight c6 so he's ready to he's
threatening e5
dubois plays f4 these moves are all kind
of logical because they're both taking
stuff and improving their pieces right
so a4 was played
rook to c7
rook to b6 guarding the knight so this
pawn is really very very dangerous and
ready to go
uh yeah so we'll get to that at the end
guys so hopefully not all of you have
seen it that's the one drawback to
picking newer games that people are
following anyway
so sometimes i give lectures on older
games and stuff i like to do that but i
do often like to you know go over the
games that are currently going on
so this is where things got very tricky
a3
but hopefully even if you've seen the
game i'll show you things that are a
little bit different so this is a very
tricky moment actually r8
so here i think nils starts to go
slightly astray so what are black's
possibilities and what do you think you
should do and why that's
one question i have for you here
so here's the main question right you
want to defend your pawn that's clear
but do you play knight before check
followed by a2 or do you start with a2
or does it not matter sometimes it just
doesn't matter
so a lot of you are saying a2 i do
believe this is correct but i think it's
correct maybe not for the ver for the
reason you're thinking
so after a2 king c3 so obviously you
can't take because of the fork
very nice
so what happens though after king c3 so
now i'm threatening to take the pawn
the question is what can you do here
and i think this is where
the correct approach to the position is
really important
so take your time what do you think you
would do here for black
so a move like d4 check is tempting but
i'm not so sure it actually does that
much like let's say here you can play
um
it's actually tricky where to go with
the king that much is not so obvious
i think even king c4 though the main
issue you have is that your
like your your pieces are actually not
so easy to improve here
so i guess you can play rook b2 knight
b3
it looks a little fragile for for white
but this knight on c6 is what i'm eyeing
and that knight's really terrible
so i'm not really sure how you're going
to continue here if you try to play d3
for example i can play king c3 i believe
and ah maybe it's not so simple you have
rook c2 check knight before check
rook here
no but then there's this
okay i'm kind of playing through moves
without thinking hard enough like
obviously rook b2 is a bad move but
i don't know maybe maybe not super
simple here
all right
so net a5 check i can always take with
the rook i think
so in this position yeah rook b4 i think
is very strong and this is the key like
you can play knight c3 but again you're
after knight b3 for example you're just
these pieces are stuck you're not really
threatening that much
so i think that this is also kind of the
wrong approach you can play knight a6
and this would actually be very similar
to the game
but i really would not suggest uh
playing this way
there's also maybe moves like rook a4
here i don't know
but rook b4 so this is the really tricky
part about
uh trying to win a position like this
this is transference of advantage
we have our beautiful apon running up
the board we all want to queen it right
but this is the key that sometimes you
can't queen it
sometimes you have to give up the ghost
and the key is to be able to transfer
your advantage meaning you go from well
i have an outside past a pawn to well i
take the pawns on the king's side and
then i win because i have extra puns
it's really hard to do that because we
all kind of wanted to queen our pawn
right
but rook b4 i think is a really really
important move here
so if white takes for example and we
take we see why we do this right this
pawn is weak this pawn is weak d4 check
is a possible tempo move that's annoying
this whole position black white's whole
position falls apart here
there's just no way that white's ever
going to survive it's just too many
pawns let's say after this for example
we could throw in d4 check but even
without it we can take
maybe d4 i don't know but even without
it like let's say let's do it just to
chase the king away right so something
like king c2
knight takes pawn
this pawn is going to fall our rooks
beautifully positioned to guard against
this knight
there's just no way we don't win this
position
so this is an example of how changing
the approach can sometimes make us make
it easier
if you're too married to one approach if
you're like i must win with my past pawn
that's when you can have problems
but when you shift
uh to a different idea that's often
where
you know
good technique comes from so in this
position f5 would have been also a
decent try
probably the better try
but here we also have a nice idea so we
take
takes and then what is the key move
now yeah i agree guys rook b4 is not so
easy to find
uh but you're kind of using your a pawn
as a distraction that's the whole idea
because white can't just take your
knight because the a pawn has to be
captured
so again how do you how do you deal with
this one
uh you can push back the king pelvics
but i would say that the main object
here is not necessarily to do that you
just want to mop up all the pawns and
win because you have three or two extra
pawns right
two extra pawns is often plenty to win a
game
it certainly is manny i think that was
one of the key factors here
so rook g6 is is a rook hang i'm
assuming you mean rook g5
can which is correct
so the idea is you're simply going to
mop up these pawns
and again white doesn't have time to try
to take this knight or anything because
the a2 pawn has to be captured so you
have to take it rook takes e5 and then
once again you're just gonna be up two
pawns
and at this level being two pawns up is
typically quite enough to win
so very very nice
and this would have been the better way
to do it so a2 is best not because
you're going to queen with a2 but to
keep the b4 square open for the rook
but grandelias was determined dead set
to queen his pawn and he thought he
could and and queen the pawn and win but
i actually don't think it was so simple
knight b3 was played
a2
so rook takes b3 checks a threat you
must play knight a1 and probably
grandelias just thought this was winning
i don't think it's actually so simple
though
so here there are different ways i think
that he probably could win again by
switching his plans but he was really
determined not to
so what do you what would you guys do
here as black this is i think also a
very very difficult moment
because i think he has to change his
plans like again
rook b1 is what was played in the game
which i think does allow black white
maybe to escape
not in an obvious way though i can tell
you this
maybe rook c6 is smart to force the king
to one side and if king b3 you can go d4
and push the second hole
oh my goodness i'm hearing a voice in
this room can you guys believe it uh
welcome caleb uh and yes caleb
unsurprisingly finds a very good move
rook c6 check
so the idea now is if the king tries to
go to the d-file you can play knight b4
and you're defending everything that's
not going to go well
so for example let's say the move king
b3 now you play d4
and there's a very very important point
here
which is that after king takes a 2 d3
rook d8 does not defend
because you have the move knight before
check
followed by knight d5
and you're blocking off this rook and
then the d-pawn's very strong
i don't think this is necessarily the
best for white like white probably would
bring the knight over or something but
this d-pawn is quite strong and once
your knight gets off you can again try
to go after these guys as well as trying
to clean your d-pawn
so i do think that this should have won
but this was the best chance he played
rook b1
and here i think that
duboff had a chance to try to draw
although it was definitely not
the most obvious
the most obvious draw again like my
eyeball test of this move was that it
should probably lose
but when i looked at it deeper it turns
out maybe not so much
so rook b1 what would you do as white
obviously the options are you can either
take this knight go to the rook end game
or you can move the knight
the rook end game seems losing to me
because
uh you
go uh circuit one mercury six rig f1 or
game two
or sorry one
rookie rook a6 or k1
king d2 i was saying
mm-hmm after wreck f1
rook a2 or something yeah so ricky to
rick f4
okay one more time so king takes a2 is
better uh because rick takes e6 is there
but then rick takes f4 takes e6
so this caleb's idea was kind of what i
thought so caleb believes that rook
takes a6 is losing
and this is kind of what i thought as
well and clearly what dubov thought
but i think if you look at it closer
it's actually not so simple and the main
reason is because this black king as i
mentioned is just a really bad piece
but this is where things come into play
so this position white has to be very
very precise
so if you go after this pawn something
like this i can play rook behind the
pawn
e6 i have time to grab the h-pawn and
once i grab the h-pawn you're kind of
pinned
your king can get back in the game but
by that time i can kind of bring my own
king in get my rook behind the pawn i
think that
this black's winning chances here are
extremely good so i do think that this
is a win
but white can be a much more clever
so in this position what do you guys
think is a possible improvement for
white
keeping in mind that you're basically
trying to deal like this is black these
are black's next moves almost for sure
so what would you like to accomplish in
this position
so rookie it's possible trying to push
the pawn immediately but i don't think
you're in time after rook g5
e6 rook takes pawn e7
rookie five the rook is behind the pawn
i can simply put it on e4 for example so
your king can't approach
and then i can just slowly start to push
my puns and even bring my king up
and you really
your your rook's not very good here so
this is the kind of thing that doesn't
ever really work
but king b3 as mentioned i saw
is quite a strong move so the idea is
now if you play rook g5
i can simply bring my king in
and once again we have the similar
situation but instead of just moving my
rook which is kind of useless i brought
my king in
and i think that this position you'll
find very difficult to win because my
king is so active my pawn is very very
strong and it takes a long time to push
these pawns
two connected passers often beat one pun
but that's only when the they're about
even and you have this thing where the
king advances with the two pawns
eventually you suck a rook for the pawn
and queen that's what i was taught
but i found so many exceptions to this
and when the king and pawn are ahead of
the two pawns
and you have such a beautiful king and
you're ready to just march ahead a
position like this is almost impossible
to win and i think with best play this
should be a drawn position the white
king is simply too good
so
a better try maybe would be something
like king g8
but here white can try to change plans
once again so how would you play this in
in this position
because now you're keeping the king cut
off right so if you're able to play king
f7 it could be very very annoying
but yeah having having a good king is i
cannot mention how important this is in
rook end games it's still the most
underestimated concept even though
everyone knows you should do it
rookie 7 is interesting but i i don't
know that it helps you permanently like
i can play
let me see actually
yeah probably king maybe rookie 4
actually so my idea now is that i have
king f8
uh as a possible idea you still have e6
though so maybe not so simple
yeah maybe actually not there
i don't think i looked at rookie seven
yeah possibly possibly you have to play
king f8 first so something like
so my idea is if you move your rook
anywhere and i go here this is a problem
so you probably have to go here
but now maybe rook g5
not so simple though
e6
i think i can do this though take and
then the rook can come back here
yeah
not so simple but i think it's good
enough
so i think here probably the best is to
actually go after the pawn more directly
so now after rook g5 i can take
and the idea is that after king f
f7 king c4 you're still close enough to
try to be able to escort your pun
and here you actually have this and this
was this was the moment where i was very
surprised i thought that this was
probably good enough with the king here
but after rook d4 it's actually enough
to
to draw and the main point is that if
you try to take this pawn
i can play rook d6 check
you can't take on e5 because of rook d5
check and you actually lose
embarrassingly
so you have to play king e7
and now i play king d5 and once again i
have this very very strong pun
and after rook h1 i play rook a6 so even
though you can check me away
this the rook checking from the sides is
just so annoying because your king has
to go somewhere terrible and then i
start pushing my pawn
so this position also i think
should be drawn
and if you try to play
rook takes e5 i have rook
g4 sorry
uh rook h4 also draws actually i just
want to illustrate
rook g5 rook g4 h4 and the whole idea is
that here
you go back and there's no way to
actually win this position this is one
of those draws because you you can't
ever try to take this pawn for example
if rook g4
king g5 i just sit
rook h4 i always have check
and the key here is that you can go here
trying to hold on to this pawn and
attack here but i check
and the problem is i just keep going
back and forth attacking your pawn and
checking you so for example if king e6 i
check go back
and eventually you can try to do this
but now the rook slides to f5 guarding
this pun
so it's very surprising to me that this
rook end game is drawn
i i would say that
it sounded to me at least like duboff
had some time
so he could have at least analyzed this
and i would say that he ended up just
giving up a piece right which
probably should lose in most instances
although it's still complicated but one
of the things i'd say is that the two
mistakes dubai have made this game uh in
this end game the big ones were his
refusal to simplify he didn't trade
knights in one situation
and here he also should have traded
nines
so i don't know if this is a pattern
with him or whether it was just
misjudgment in two cases but if i were a
coach or something i obviously normally
would not coach a player so much
stronger than me
but if i were a coach i'd be like so is
this a tendency do you always resist
simplifying when you should
because sometimes players who like
complex positions will not simplify when
they absolutely should
but yeah really crazy end game and i
definitely think that there are drawing
chances with best play there
but obviously not so easy to execute in
the end he played knight c2
and this actually became really
interesting because it looks like okay
he's up a piece now but after f5
i've mentioned how much i hate this king
right
and
this this king is so bad even here it is
difficult to win because you have this
beautiful pawn structure
and you have discoordinated pieces
but grenellius does a really excellent
job
especially at first
so
he plays he takes f5
g takes f5 he throws in this check
the main idea is that the king here
looks nice but you can actually play
stuff like knight before and then rook
check and stuff like that and it
actually is uh
not so
not so easy um and you can actually you
can also check here and the king has to
then move away again
so moving up doesn't actually help so he
plays back
and then here what is his idea his idea
his move here i really really like
actually and it's not such an obvious
one
so he goes for rook f1
so the main idea is that if you simplify
into this rook end game this is a lost
rook end game you're going to take and
go back
notice how with the king on d4 of course
you could not do that but then you'd
have rook to one check
and it's kind of weird because at first
it looks like oh just rook c6 should win
easily but
it's actually not so simple even after a
move like e6 just trying to do this like
what exactly are you doing here
uh it actually does not look simple at
all
um so
like if you try to go here then i pin
you it's like this is kind of one of
those things where
it looks simple and nice but this is not
simple at all
so rook back to f1 very very nice move
f6
so this move is also very very clever
because now
what would you guys do here as black
once again i think he has to find very
very accurate moves which again at first
he does
yeah it's a pretty good point james
actually like in the in the old days you
see end games played really accurately
and it's not because they were
necessarily better end game players
uh actually yasser i talked to yasser
about this he really explained this to
me well he's like they just had so much
time and a million people working on
them that they were able to find most of
the details in these end games whereas
now people have to play it on sudden
death it's a lot harder
so
yeah so knight c5 was played in the game
uh taking the pawn actually it turns out
is not so simple because i can throw in
this check very important
getting the king off this pawn and then
i take
and this position actually should
probably be drawn because again your
king is just not good enough and this
h-pawn serves as a very nice distraction
so even though you have the two pawns
because my king is going to be active in
front of him your king's going to be cut
off you're going to find winning this
position to be
quite
impossible
so taking on f6 is not best knight c5 is
a good move
but it's still not over he plays rook a7
and here once again black has to be very
accurate so
what would you guys play
and again i'm not positive that his way
is the only way to win each position but
i do think that he played this part of
the game like very very well and it was
only because of a mistake later he
allowed dubois to have some drawing
chances
so to give you a hint what's the piece
i've been complaining about all game
what's the only piece that makes this
game complicated
uh you can't really take the pawn though
because this pawn is is quite pinned on
f6 so
yes the king is the piece i've been
complaining about and king g8 is indeed
the good move 96 looks uh tempting but
after rookie seven you're kind of in the
same bind only worse because your
knight's attacked
so i think this move is very very nice
so duboff takes this pawn with check so
he has the connected passers but at
least the king is on a much better
square now
so that definitely
helps duba plays rook c7
grendelius plays knight e6
rook b7
knight g5 all of this is good
king e3
and this is where
life gets very complicated i do believe
that
grandelias here
could have won
but it's again not obvious like it's not
easy so what would you guys do here is
black
and the lines get really really crazy so
you're you know it's very very difficult
to see everything but i'm curious what
you guys would go for
the key is about coordination you need
to make sure that your rook and knight
coordinate well enough so that white
can't just either draw with these
continuous rook checks
or be able to push the pawn or get the
king too far in and stuff like that
like if white moves their king up you
have to make sure you have a defense to
everything
so rook f5 was played in the game
oh i was i was
i think i was fiddling with the bottom
sorry about that
so rookie one check is actually a very
clever move so first of all if king d4
you can play this check and then this
pawn drops and that should be easy
enough once you eliminate the connected
passers the the win tends to be a lot
easier
unsurprisingly so king f4 is the move i
would worry about
but here it turns out that even with
this k marching up the board you're able
to win so the winning line is d4
king f5
and i was really surprised this was such
an easy win but it turns out you can
play d3
and this is where things get uh very
complicated so there are two main there
are three main defenses here uh
if king g6
you can play rook takes e5 this is the
important thing and you're not getting
mated with rook b8
and once you're not getting mated the
d-pawn should be very very strong so
this is kind of the first thing simple
enough but you still have to pay
attention
the other one that you have to watch out
for is the move king jesus oop not the
move king g6 sorry the move rook d7
uh yeah and i should mention also the
third one you basically if white keeps
checking you you get out this way this
actually helps black so the best defense
is rook d7
and here
this is where things get very strange
so you play rook e3 guarding your pawn
king g6
so if you take here now white can draw
by playing check rookie 8 rook takes d3
and there's actually just no easy way to
win this position because after
something like net f7 you're guarding
your pawn but you also can't really move
so i could probably just move my rook
like along here something like this and
it's really hard to actually win because
you're just constantly getting harassed
and rook's going there next of course
don't fall for this
but apart from that this is actually
really really hard to win because your
rook's so passive that's kind of the key
so that doesn't really work out
um so you have to play king e8
and then the key is after rook d5 you
have to move knight f7 now
and here because you're behind this pawn
you're able to win
so
kind of nice not crazy complicated but
allowing the king up like checking the
king up to f5 would be very hard to do
in a game and he wasn't able to do it
especially with limited time rook five's
what he played
but here it turns out duba is able to
draw he checks
so grand ellis is just gaining time he
forces the king to e8 rookie 7 check
king f8
and king d4
so the king's coming up the board
grendellius plays knight f7
king takes d5 rook takes h5
so king e4 was played rook g5
and this is where dubov maybe missed an
opportunity
so the way to the path to drawing
is a little bit hazardous though
so the first move i think is obvious
enough what would you guys play here is
white i can give you the hint king f4 is
what he played in the game which is a
mistake which loses but what other
what move do you think he has to play
here
e6 very good
so if knight d8 i can just play rook h7
i'm threatening mate in this pawn so
once you lose the h pawn you're not
going to win the game at least you
shouldn't with king and knight king
knight and rook against king rook
you have some chances but
usually pretty small uh king and bishop
rook against king rook you have more
chances
but uh yeah i'm not going to do it so
knight d6 check is the best try in my
opinion
and here it's very important so this
this decision is easy enough there's
only one square which draws for the
white king
and this is the tricky part when you're
facing knights in an end game you have
to find squares where you don't get
forked and and checked all the time
that's the hard part so king f3 allows
rook f5 check and this pawn drops that's
not so good
king d4 and king
e3 allow this knight check so you have
to go to d3
but here's where the tricky part comes
rook g3 check
and once again you only have one square
which draws
and this is where things get a little
trickier and maybe this is where he
wasn't sure
um i don't know if he used his time or
not but
where does the wet king go
so king e2 is a reasonable guess but the
problem now is after rook g6
rook d7 knight e8
you're kind of losing your pawns if e7
king f7 i win easily so f7 and now i
take the pawn with check
and then my knight is free
going to dark squares doesn't work if
here i check and take a rook
d2 is i think bad for a few reasons not
because of this but i think
i can go for
this move again and the idea now is if
you play rook d7 here i can check and
take your pawn and that should win
pretty easily
so you actually have to go to c2
so it's very illogical right you're
moving away directly away from where the
action is but sometimes like most of the
time you want your king participating in
the end game but sometimes you just need
that king out of the way
and the rook and two pawns do their job
beautifully here after rook g6 you play
rook d7
98 again is forced
and then f7 and this is a draw
if you move the knight i check here and
you lose so you pretty much have to sack
the knight in
this is a pretty easy draw the h-pawn is
the hardest pawn to win with and this is
no exception this is just very simple
draw with king up and eventually you you
force the like the king's even cut off
so after something like this
look over let's say you push i just do
this to do to force the rook away and
then my king comes up and
you're not going to win this position
very counterintuitive right
but sometimes the king just needs to be
out of the way right
but he played king of four and it seems
like most of you saw this game
but for those of you who haven't anyone
here's the move that duboff missed and a
really really cool move it is
i actually have a good memory of moves
like this i actually it wasn't knight h8
it was a move knight d2 to b1 i managed
to beat garev with in a u.s championship
one time and it was again a move he
completely missed because it was a
backwards knight move
so here knight h8 is is the idea in that
position it was knight b1
with the idea that the knight comes to
c3 and is very strong and here is knight
h8 with idea knight comes to g6
so that's kind of the the hall of thing
that's hard to see but sometimes
backward knight moves uh to reposition
the knight are very nasty
and this just wins because you just take
all the pawns with check like he plays
king e4 if rook h7 you can check and no
matter what happens you just skate this
guy with check if here you take with
check
if here you take with check and it's
just over
so he plays king e4 knight here but now
the knight's on a beautiful square
and there's nothing much to do with
rookie 6 king f7 is an easy win
so you have to go here check
h5
rook g7 and here it's just a matter of
coordination rook g5
knight e5 and i like this last a little
bit he plays rook g7
hoping for this
which is a draw
but grandelia simply plays knight f7 and
now the rook's trapped
and once you trade the rooks it's going
to be a very easy win
something like this you can take
and you just put the pawn on h3
and now the king's tied to it and you
just take and come up the board just
make sure you don't do this with knight
on g4 and pawn and h2 that happens to be
a draw
but anyway a really really complicated
game
but this is what i'd call real life
technique where there's lots of mistakes
there's lots of stuff that can happen
you saw there was really good resistance
in parts
but overall it's really about getting it
done and you have to be willing to
change advantages and change how you
think about the position a lot and
sometimes you can't win the way you
picture in your head you have to kind of
figure out a way to do it and with very
little time grandelias did a great job
of organizing his forces and even though
he made some mistakes along the way i
thought it was a really really cool and
instructive game
so
i hope that
hope you enjoyed the end game
and uh yeah as you can see it's
amazingly complicated even analyzing it
it was really hard for me because i
would come to my own conclusions and
then sometimes i'd check with the
computer and it'd be like no no you're
just wrong
so that's the way it goes
but anyway i hope you guys enjoy this
lecture i'll be here next couple weeks
so stay tuned for more of them
uh but for now i am off so have a good
night everyone see you
[Music]
you